dr lola bergman was an accomplished
senior researcher for the scp foundation
her years of hard work studying
anomalies and dedication to the
foundation had earned her a level three
security clearance
allowing her to access a bevy of secret
information across the foundation's vast
network as a researcher and a scientist
dr bergman was the naturally inquisitive
type she wanted to know everything there
was to know about the strange and
esoteric universe around her
that's why when she heard about the file
for scp-2000
one of the organization's best kept
secrets she was hooked
the only problem was that just to view
the file you had to be on the o5 council
or have a special subset of level 4
clearance known as
4 2 000. unfortunately dr bergman was
only a level three
but you know what they say the forbidden
fruit always
tastes the sweetest dr bergman had given
the foundation years of service
what could the harm be in breaking the
rules and getting a peek behind the
curtain
just this once through somewhat
deceptive means dr bergman managed to
get her hands on some four two thousand
clearance credentials
and decided to access the file on an
encrypted personal device
they'd never even know but as she
entered the credentials
she found herself suddenly looking at an
image on its face
nothing an image of a dirt road in a
field with tiny white text reading
remember us but this was a powerful
cognitohazardous image capable of
causing immediate incapacitation the
next thing she knew
she was laying on the ground unconscious
when she woke up
she was no longer a doctor at the scp
foundation
she was on the street corner unable to
remember her own name
let alone her history all she could do
was murmur something about a secret
under yellowstone national park dr
bergman's years of service had meant
nothing in the end scp-2000 is an
anomalous asset
so vital to not only the foundation but
the entire world
that so much as attempting to access it
without the proper clearance
leads to immediate termination but
what's really hidden under yellowstone
national park
and why are the foundation higher-ups so
intent on keeping it secret
even from most of their own ranks of
course yellowstone national park itself
is no stranger to anomalous activity
the entire national park is technically
an scp known as
scp-1422 while it since has been
neutralized
scp-14 caused all members of the scp
foundation to have no awareness of
yellowstone national park
prior to 2007 but the true nature of
scp-2000
the secret hidden under yellowstone
national park is not only stranger than
scp-1422
but also depending on your perspective
either profoundly relieving
or utterly terrifying but before you can
truly understand the purpose and gravity
of scp-2000
or the deus ex machina we need to talk
about the end
of the world in foundation parlance
k-class scenarios are events which have
drastic implications on the state of
society
normality or even life the most
dangerous and feared of all of these are
xk
class scenarios which are for all
intents and purposes
the apocalypse there are a worrying
number of anomalies capable of bringing
about an
xk class scenario if the foundation ever
dropped the ball on their protection or
containment
while the foundation believes that
prevention is always preferable to the
cure
what happens when prevention doesn't
work what happens when our worst fears
are realized
and the end truly comes for us all the
answer is
scp-2000 happens
simply put the anomaly is a reset button
a chance to start over when all life has
been compromised by anomalous activity
2000 is a giant and mysterious facility
beneath yellowstone national park
the entrance is disguised as a disused
park ranger station
feeding into a facility that burrows
miles down into the earth
it's a place that contains incredible
anomalous technologies capable of
bringing the world back to its former
glory
even after the worst happens only a
select few personnel are allowed to work
at the facility
keeping its machinery maintained in case
the day comes where we ever need to use
it again
these personnel are not allowed to come
and go as they please
and their memories of 2000 are wiped if
they're ever reassigned to different
foundation duties elsewhere
why all the secrecy scp-2000 is the
foundations and humanities
lifeboat and as such the base is well
guarded
both from potential human threats as
well as anomalous activity
and reality warpers the surface level
entrance to the base is surrounded by a
number of strategically placed scranton
reality anchors or
sras these devices largely constructed
of corrosion resistant beryllium bronze
alloy
keep certain type of reality bending
anomalies from manifesting their powers
within the vicinity of the base
however these are just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to the
state-of-the-art foundation technology
employed within and around scp-2000
you probably have a lot of questions and
that's understandable
what kind of technology can possibly
reverse an apocalypse
and what did we mean when we said we may
need to use it again
well listen up because this is going to
be a lot to take in
scp-2000 is powered by a liquid fluoride
thorium reactor
stabilized by five zyank anastasiko's
constant temporal sinks
and hosts to the most miraculous
technology of all
five hundred thousand bright zarteon
hominoid replicators
utilizing geothermal energy from the
volcanic activity in the area
the base could potentially remain
operational forever if foundation staff
kept up with maintenance the grand
majority of the space in this huge
subterranean facility is taken up by
building materials
construction equipment factory machinery
agricultural equipment
and computer database storage why
well let's explain the process of the
apocalypse and how it relates to the
activities of scp-2000
in any k-class or end-of-the-world
scenario that doesn't destroy
scp-2000 in the process any surviving
foundation member can enact procedure
cya009
while any foundation facilities globally
can monitor the unfolding situation
while scp-2000 is waiting for the all
clear to do its thing
remaining foundation sites set in motion
what is known as the ganymede protocol
this involves collecting and preserving
materials which could be useful
during the recreation process however
it's extremely possible that in the
sudden
xk class end of the world scenario there
may be no surviving foundation personnel
or at least not enough to maintain any
kind of organization
thankfully there are fail-safe measures
for such a scenario
during the periods of extended inaction
caused by an apocalypse that destroys
most human life
scp-2000 will gradually autonomously
relax its security measures any
personnel regardless of clearance will
be able to activate the next stage of
the process when this occurs
if such a thing doesn't happen for an
extended period the security measures
lapse further to the point that even the
presence of an animal could activate it
this would set into motion procedure
lazarus zero one
humanity's last hope for survival that's
where the five hundred thousand bright
zarteon hominoid replicators or bzhrs
come in
these incredible pieces of anomalous
technology are capable of perfectly
cloning the entire human race
from any given period in the last 20
years even down to their ages and
memories
thanks to class g hallucinogens and
developmental hypnotherapy
with a warm-up period of five days these
machines are capable of creating 100 000
viable non-anomalous humans per day the
facility keeps records of all known
human alleles
and is capable of recreating any lost
human genomes or generating as many new
and unique genomes as necessary to
repopulate human civilization
which humans the machines generate
depends on the period of time the
machine is ordered to replicate
it will first reproduce prominent
cultural and political figures
as well as the acting top brass of the
scp foundation to coordinate the
recreation effort of course
the machine will then recreate well
everyone else
you're probably wondering if the world
outside scp-2000 has been destroyed
then what good is creating all these new
humans if they have nothing to go back
to
thankfully scp-2000 has a contingency
for rebuilding both the infrastructure
of civilization
as well as society itself the first
generation clones will have one mission
rebuild and they will have quite
literally all the resources
in the world to do it in addition to
having all the physical equipment for
buildings and agriculture
scp-2000 stores an immense amount of
data
which is appropriate considering the
whole facility is basically a huge
backup drive for life
itself they have the entire internet
backed up
as well as the sum of all human memory
and a wide cultural base with copies of
thousands of famous works of art
music and literature they have all the
scattered jigsaw pieces of the time that
came before
and it's their job to put the whole
thing back together
it's expected that many of the first
generation of clones will die in this
process
but that's fine with the bzhrs working
at full capacity
anyone can be replicated as the
population increases and spreads across
the globe
rebuilding and recolonizing old
settlements population growth will
increase
exponentially once society returns to
some kind of normal
decades after the activation of
procedure lazarus zero one
it becomes the foundation's task to
restore the psychological and historical
status quo
administrators will falsify dendro
chronological astronomical and
radiometric dating records to make it
seem as though history never paused
they'll then employ amnestic agent nue 5
and mass to erase
and reconstruct the memories of the
entire human population
up until the chosen time prior to the
end of the world
as far as civilization knows nothing
ever happened
history never stopped and life goes on
it may seem comforting at first to know
that the ultimate contingency is out
there
even if there's a containment breach of
astronomical proportions
and the world as we know it ends there's
still a way
out it means that there's hope even in
the bleakest situations
but of course there are always caveats
after all
if a deal seems too good to be true it's
safe to assume it probably is
whether any of this works is dependent
on two factors
the first is that no anomalies or human
insurgents infiltrate the scp-2000
facility
and destroy the equipment within it's
for this reason that discussion of the
facility is so restrictive
if ever a powerful reality warper
discovered and gained access to the
facility
we would lose our lifeboat the second
factor is the overall integrity of the
machines
after all without proper maintenance
it's not hard for the technology to
malfunction
often to truly horrifying results the
failure of some sra and x-ax components
is believed to have caused erroneous
bzhr activity
resulting in the production of 10
million humanoid entities with internal
biology wildly inconsistent with
humanity
these beings remained unconscious for
five weeks before dying
in the event of an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario
well-maintained machines can reproduce
the human race but all it takes is one
little malfunction
to release 10 million mutants who are
effectively dead
on arrival even with scp-2000 in our
back pocket
the fate of the world still lives on a
knife's edge
but in a way that's not even the most
frightening part of the existence of
scp-2000
seeing as the machine can perfectly
reproduce reality without leaving a
trace behind
it raises the question how many times
has this happened you may be surprised
but the foundation can confirm this
occurred at least twice
in recorded history but can you ever
really be sure of how many times your
clone has crawled out of the bzhr
we received a disturbing clue to the
reality of the situation
when human remains were discovered on
site at scp-2000
all tests indicate that the remains are
between 450
and 700 years old and have been matched
to the very much alive dr
alto clef who has no knowledge of how
these remains came to be there
the only other thing found within the
remains was a no hermetically sealed and
a plastic document sleeve
the note read why do we have to build
this thing
when did we do it how long have we been
doing it
do we even know and the answer
no we don't and for everyone's peace of
mind
it's probably best to just forget about
it if you can
now go check out scp-096 the shy guy
and scp-087 the stairwell for more
strange and surprising stories
from the scp foundation